White House looking even more
incompetent as we finally learn the
reason behind defense secretary Lloyd
Austin's mysterious Hospital trip Walter
Reed revealing that the secretary
underwent a minimally invasive surgical
procedure to treat and cure prostate
cancer it all started in December 22nd
when Austin had the surgery everything
went fine he even went home but then
Austin had to go back to the hospital on
January 1st because of an
infection still doesn't really explain
why Austin felt the need to keep
everybody including the president in the
dark for days the Pentagon couldn't
explain it
either who's decision was it not to
alert the president that the defense
secretary had prostate cancer we're
providing that information to you as
we've received it uh we received that
this afternoon and and we're providing
it to you now clearly you didn't know
did Chief of Staff did the chief of
staff know I'm not going to go into the
specifics on who specifically knew what
when and where he was not informed until
last Friday that secretary Austin was in
the hospital he was not informed until
this morning that the root cause of that
hospitalization was prostate cancer is
there a lack of trust between the
Pentagon and the White House we have
complete confidence in the secretary
that is something that we have said the
president has complete confidence in the
secretary wow but that doesn't explain
why Joe Biden in his White House didn't
even notice the defense secretary was in
the
ICU what kind of commander-in-chief is
President Biden
that at a time when American forces are
Under Fire in the Middle East he can go
days without knowing that his defense
secretary is in a hospital bed at no
time
was the ability for the United States
military to defend our national security
interest compromise why should we
believe anything that this
Administration tells us about anything
ever again the Pentagon has
been very very honest with themselves
about uh the um the challenge to to to
credibility by what by what has
transpired here judge Janine uh you are
a medical doctor as well so let's go to
you first yes would you
describe prostate cancer surgery as
elective no or minimally invasive nobody
says you know I really don't need it but
I think I'll go in and add prostate
surgery okay plus now we know for sure
what we didn't know yesterday and that
is on December 22nd and he was under
general anesthesia when you're under
general anesthesia it's for during the
time of the surgery and then for several
hours later when you're groggy and this
and that but you know the crazy part
about it is and and I get the Kirby is
dealing with the bad facts that he has
but when he says at no time was the
ability to defend our national security
interest compromised that's hogwash okay
at this time American uh service men and
women are being hit in Iraq and in Syria
no one is doing anything about it
there's no National Security meeting no
NSC Council meetings no one is talking
to anyone else really is is there like a
a memo that says okay we'll allow this
many to get hit one right now I
understand is in critical condition more
than 50 of them have traumatic brain
injury which is a lifelong injury do
they not care or how can they prove to
us that they do care in light of this
and I want to say one more thing the
cabinet uh there is now requirement that
they do a review of protocols really in
2024 we're going to review protocols
okay your local high school principal
has a protocol when he or she isn't
there the vice principal's in charge my
local DA's office when I wasn't around
as a DA there was a delegation of
authority that had to be filed with the
county clerk as to who was in charge
when I when I'm not there okay it's that
simple and we don't have it for the
Secretary of SEC def SEC or de SE SE def
okay and finally is anyone talking to
anyone blinkin during this period of
time is in Cutter he's in Greece he's in
uh cutter Greece uh as well as turkey
and there's another country who is he
talking to about his meetings in these
countries the president isn't talking to
him he's missing an action he's not
speaking to the Secretary of Defense who
is he having these discussions with
Jordan Turkey cutter and Greece is he
calling his mother and saying Ma how do
you think I did over there no one is in
charge Dana well I think that the 30-day
review is absolutely Preposterous is
takes 30 seconds to review this
situation and the SEC the deputy
secretary who saying let's do this
30-day review it was her job to tell
everybody what was happening in the
first place and she didn't do it so
that's like another 30 seconds plus I
hate group work I hate it I hated it
from when I was a kid so especially
group work that is foisted upon you
because of somebody else's misbehavior
or or uh if they did something wrong
well now the chief of staff at the White
House has told everyone in the cabinet
that they have to turn in a memo by
January 12th that tells them exactly
what the procedures are like nobody else
needs to do this group work it's that's
again that just makes everybody angry um
five days with no contact does seem
inconceivable to us but it does o open
the White House to these questions and I
think that they know that because you
can tell from Kirby's answer and at the
Pentagon that they're like look we got
bad facts here we don't have a lot to
work with of course we want the
secretary to get better of course we do
but his judgment is a question if the
Trump Secretary of Defense had gone
missing for five days and then they were
finding out about this now the media
would have gone crazy and all the de
Democrats would have said the Russians
must have something on him and so I I
think that this is an untenable
situation I said this morning I would
say I'm sorry you don't feel well but
I'll see you in my oval in the Oval
Office at 8: a.m. and then I'll see you
out o Greg yeah you know we had Michelle
Obama in the a block and she said
government does everything yes
everything badly except the military
which used to be a meritocracy and that
may not be for long but this thing
called government that supposedly does
everything for us can't keep track of
anything right the trillions in covid
funds where did that go the millions of
illegal immigrants the crime on our
streets our secretary of defense it's
like if the government were your Uber
driver you would be at the bottom of a
lake uh the big deal here is the chain
of command right there was none no one
knew what was going on it's like when
when Jesse's off the five and we can't
get Joey Jones because Jesse had parked
in his handicap spot listen I was in a
rush yeah but it is it is amazing how
this but it is the big question like
where was the chain of command and who's
going to keep tabs on the white
supremacist in the PTA in in the
military we got to be safe from like
servicemen who own Gadson flags and
refuse to read books by imram kendi by
the way I have to put on my Men's Health
hat because I was the editor of men's
health you can't prostate cancer is can
be called elective surgery because it's
based on the aggressiveness of the
growth of the tumor because sometimes
almost all men have a some prostate
cancer in them it's just depending on
how slow it grows whether you want to
use radiation or a radical prostectomy
but in that but in that sense it is
elective wow are you going to take the
hat off now no I'm going to keep it on
oh keep it on for the rest of the show
it's an invisible hat oh good uh Harold
for
so I think it was irresponsible uh for
the
secretary uh in two fronts number one
and I I hold them in high regard but I
think it's two fronts number one when
the deputy secretary was given this
Authority she was not told at least the
reports and she has said she was not
told why or what was happening uh they
need to review that protocol too and two
more importantly I don't understand how
you don't call the commander and chief
if even if it's a confidential
conversation you say say to the
president I I'm taking I'm I'm I'm
looking up my own Health uh I heard I
think on one of the shows earlier uh one
of the doctors one of our doctors
in-house doctors on Fox say that it
would have also been useful just from uh
uh the element of how African-American
men how we deal with this uh prostate
cancer uh and how many African-American
men are unwilling for whatever reason to
to go and have the screening uh there
was another public good that could have
been done uh I don't necessarily agree
that we were as compromised as some as
maybe some of the language around the
table but I do agree it's irresponsible
uh and this is I hope it's fixed but
it's something that should have been
avoided okay so you're going to go get
your prostate check on camera for the
show and for the country I will be I
will be doing exams in The Green Room
the together I I brought my gloves two
black guys in a white guy go get that's
right it'll be tomorrow but ahead did he
forget about the whole Sanctuary thing
Chicago's left-wing mayor claims Texas
is attacking cities run by black Leaders
with waves of migrants hey Sean Hann
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else